hello I'm calling from the team of
Master Shake Ashla about your wealth
yogi program
hello else what you do now let's see how
your suffering let's see how much our
life's gone that bloody pieces so that I
can make weed a bit more money out of
you on a wing and a prayer that you may
get somewhere further if not you're go
to debtors prison and probably be sent
to paucity basis of near-field herbs
groups yeah why don't you guys to buy
flowers rip off the pedal so you could
throw them at him as like some kind of
hero and yes I worship come here come
with gold how much money did you lose in
your experience and as a single parent
that's got to be devastating and
[Music]
devastating as a bit of an
understatement did you say you wouldn't
to cardiac arrest and yeah it brought
back six iron she took them to stabilize
me I'm not be telling our hospital even
I was so so L I'm the cause of all the
trauma of what happened
I just basically give up I didn't want
to be here anymore start putting stuff
up my facebook I'm making people aware
and I got an email today basically
trapped in me and but I won't be
tracking and I read it good afternoon
Eileen it was observed by our management
team that you have published negative
videos which negatively showed and
discussed the internal materials and
content of our company's program please
remove these in the next 24 hours
otherwise management team will take the
appropriate legal action against you it
was signed very politely stay blessed oh
no Dave hey we're about to sue you
stay black welcome to coffee break today
we have Eileen and Paul they are victims
of Eriko and they wanted to speak out
first of all let's start with you Eileen
tell us
aftermath of what happened before we
rewind before we go back and talk about
how it all unfolded what happened you
with Eriko why are you speaking now
forgive me if I get emotional juice and
cry because it's been really horrific
and traumatic experience for me and the
aftermath is for me my system due to all
the stress my system absolutely crushed
and I ended up on husband and I neared
it-- and coming out of where I am I got
a sense of strength and I sing more
people speak a night and because of what
happened tell em Charlene's lastly and
holding things in I'm from suffering a
lot of magical problems myself it's time
for us to come out and make our voice
heared they spoken and and don't let
these people away with things anymore we
have to stand our ground we all have to
come together as a community and not be
intimidated by these people who are just
scamming hard-working and people for me
even being long parents was a child to
have that responsibility and you just
want to give your family and your
children a better life and to be knocked
down and maybe even taken away so for me
is my point of my story is to help
prevent people and who make me as strong
with me and to come back and speak art
and and I actually think there could be
a lot of suicides people who've not able
to recover from the expenses and stuff
because I know I was absolutely broken
I'm the only way I could put in the
world so I was broken because of my
experience how much money did you lose
in your experience I couldn't be away
for three months and I got
scandens do not only one of the programs
but after the wife yogi program is over
I stayed on today another one which was
not very nice either
I've been off work your cotton hotels
and your your B&B is whatever the boats
on all the costs of ten thousand hands I
know it is a second and as a single
parent that's gotta be devastating and
devastating Lisbon for understatement
a lot of these people there's no kids
they know little my bunny kids have no
responsibilities they have no
responsibility even of death Muslim
Muslim have their parents and their
loved ones and they make active hard
lies when they don't even know what a
hard life is and for the life of me and
so many other vulnerable people who are
putting all our trust into these people
and there are programs I'm going and
just being scammed and enough enough
more people need to speak out I mean
need more people like you and to help us
with speaking out and not be afraid or
intimidated by these people and take a
stand together Thank You Ivan can I jump
in and say my experience at this stage
yeah jump off so I didn't take on the
same program as Ilene and at the end of
it I really felt left high and dry by
now the cost of the program was supposed
to be $3,000 White's priced in dollars
we can only guess so
that's the amount that I spend out but
what we will develop as this
conversation goes on is that there was a
grading system halfway through the
course whereby master formerly known as
haricots or whatever other name he wants
this week and was going to do a creaming
process as in let's see I'll get the one
that really good at computers or mildly
gullible and
in between the two we'll take those away
from the rest of this course so I can
nurture Nate try them to get them to be
my 18 as long as they play ball
they were sent down the chance to spend
am i correct not if you'd say this is
great
hundreds and hundreds of pounds on
buying flowers to rip all the petals off
so that we could all throw flowers he
strolled in with it - boy oh no no let
me let me restate that yeah why don't
you guys to buy flowers rip off the
pedal so you could throw them at him as
like some kind of hero and yes he's my
worship come here comes God and the
walked along the flower path of the
petals from sacked the Lotus crossed
legs on this chair and everyone does the
namaste bollocks in front of him
no yes yes well we didn't have to bathe
large or sad but we hadn't ripped the
petals off the flowers and I seen the
price and was disgusting Wow Wow yeah
that yeah it sounds amazing well let's
get into it now that we have kind of
both of your a little bit about what
happened what I did can I just finish
that because you wanted the ending sure
yeah yeah absolutely
it's because of this dissatisfaction
it's crucial to see he stood up having
had all this adulation of flowers and
all that and giving his little speeches
and then handed out our worthless bits
of paper to say that we completed the
course and then started to announce who
he had privately selected to be part of
the I am creator close to God experience
speed and you can probably have a guess
that maybe myself and Arlene were not on
that list then the names ran out and he
said well that's the end of the wealthy
okie scheme thank you for coming along
for the last month if your name wasn't
called out
then good luck with your future all you
were taught in that month was out to be
a Tele sales guy to sell I am creator
products and courses and things it had
no intrinsic value whatsoever and inside
his umbrella in the real world because
you'd sold yourself to the devil in the
clickfunnels and the the aweber process
everything that you have been taught
would only be good for selling his
product onwards correct yes the other
bottom line is within the 15 people I do
not know one person although they may
talk about it that earned one penny I
certainly did not receive any Commission
whatsoever for what my few results
Arlene I don't believe you saw a whisper
either now and I don't know any of the B
lispers that got anything some of the
aliases may have been enticed in so I
don't think they're so how much did this
course cost again in that the basic
price should be three thousand dollars
or pounds depending on which way you
were doing it okay three thousand pounds
to go become a teller salesman that's
all you are a Tele sales rep to be your
average the commission was 10% on
product ten percent now I've worked
commission only sales on its yellow
pages sales rep brewery industry game
the Machine I've worked for companies I
understand sales but if you're working
commission only ten percent is a
travesty plus has no embedded sales
tracking of your leads being allocated
you for a lifetime so it was a we're
going to get to this as you
retrograde through the beginning and the
middle but nothing of what was signed up
it was a free-for-all
as it was in the office staff are in
chaos and have no structure and we had
15 people that didn't know what their
leads were they were allocated on a bit
of a but was it a Google Docs sheet and
you put your name down that you want you
to ring these three these people now
let's understand let's take this into
the worst scenario their offices being
in Lincoln have no mobile signal
connection we're in the middle of
nowhere you don't get one bar
plus your leads are in 0.1 America time
zones and India time zones with some in
England time zones so you've got people
going up stairways wandering around
rainy car parks on little mobile phones
trying to look like the budding
professional hello I'm calling from the
team of master Xie xiè about your wealth
yogi program hello ask what you do now
let's see how really now let's see how
you're suffering
let's see how much your life's beyond
our bloody pieces so that I can make
weed a bit more money out of you on a
wing and a prayer that you may get
somewhere further if not your go to
debtors prison and probably be sent a
positive eight or seven years beetle
clubs group oh my goodness that's quite
the experience
let's get is anything of what I've said
there cuz I know I express is anything
there Arleen inaccurate of what I've
said no everything's and cracked and we
haven't even touched iceberg yeah we do
you say you want actually give me the
shivers of what what happens let's go
let's go through it okay so I want you
guys to take me through first your why
you got involved with master Sri Yash
Khurana or whatever his name is Eric ho
then tell me about like tell me about
the experience of okay you pay the money
you get involved what I want to go
through specifically is how Eric hoes
promises did not lead up to what he was
saying so I want to hear about his
promises and then I want to hear about
the actual deliverables so once again
I'll jump on on that and I'll try and
keep mine snappy under sure I pumped
into one of their members at a travel
trade show because I'm a tour guide and
the stuff with regard sales and the
internet which I was not very good at
seemed a good idea so I bought of it a
little bit of a program which I worked
my way through so that got me into the
system they then had a little bit of a
seminar up in link and I did that for
three days and well the stuff there that
I didn't know about sales and marketing
so I'll take that as an in
a couple of days then getting on to what
is the subject of our matter this new
scheme this new schemes to come on board
to be part of this great global
operation that's going to be bigger and
better to understand what's going on
called the wealthy okie now it was going
to be by a strict very strict select
program whereby you had to pass an
interview or boy this interview is gonna
be very strict and you had to answer all
the right questions so the right answers
to make sure for these are limited
spaces of only 30 spaces and they're
crying out as we speak for these bases
you don't know how lucky you are to have
been selected to have these spaces so
when the phone call comes be ready
because you might even out be asked for
the secret code word needless to say you
get the phone call have you got enough
money to spend three thousand quid to
come up to Lincoln or as well San Diego
then to be on this program what what if
what wasn't missing in your life well
missing is finance because you know I am
really sort of reinvesting in my future
I work day to day and not all the usual
pain points that we learned about and
were taught how to possibly manipulate
with others I go on the wealth yogi
thing initially to San Diego I paid the
thousand plus upfront in a couple of
installments then it was supposed to be
San Diego then with a few weeks to go it
changed to Lincoln and I went in sorting
I would be nurtured to be part of a
growing company I've seen all the videos
the law of attraction I can't quite get
that coincidences that breed results
I'll think well that can be quite
interesting I'll go down that road
because some of the stuff has been
interesting and this is going to take us
on a journey and I thought within a
month that journey am I prepared to
subject myself to yoga well that's an
area
Arleen love the yoga I was you know I'm
sixty something a little bit unmatched
fit but it was intensive intensive yoga
which was will come all
so of what that is because the yoga also
went into manifestation which even
master edged on the fact that he was
deliberately brainwashing the people in
order to be the perfect students to go
with the flow to get the end product for
what he wanted out of the individual so
that is my journey
what Arlene will say I think will take
them I would like her to take the
manifestation and the the yoga further
because she did more than that but
that's how I went in but it was on day
three of the course then it became
blatantly obvious that we were being
trained to be telling sales
representatives and nothing more
ten sales representatives on Commission
only and that's what our function was
that's where I'll leave my beginnings
and that's in day three when we chose to
go down in the absence of our own
business plan the I am creator direction
which is a fatal error because then
everything you taught was only useful
for being part of the iron creator team
so I'll go over to Arlene because that's
my little story and it's not complete
but she'll fill in other bits
go ahead Eileen well for me it was this
I'm quite special getting on this
special path years ago helped me with my
mindset so much I am the most driven
positive person you'll ever meet I've
done all the Tony Robbins and attended
dispersion colleges or spent thousands
and I don't have a bad word to say about
any other program that I've done I came
across and he was just eric whole
transition into mastery cash not a mega
was July and God totally sucked in by
one a single new trip I thought oh this
this dude's amazing I have to work with
this dude I actually had time to do the
Tony Robbins yesterday in December and I
thought no I'm going to the Erica one
instead I joined their creator Circle
and don't all this on the Hein arts give
up my son DS and to go onto the
meditations and all got sucked into the
whole inside
he's doing his wrist infinity bonds
where every Sunday once a month he's
meant to charge them and that's not
money scam so then hands I let me sorry
to stop you what what is it affinity
bans charging oh he had to be the first
100 to sign up to CC trust if we signed
up CC Plus she got for $19 so that's why
I signed up this is across uh what do
you what do you mean he's charging them
I'm sorry it's a yellow band on yeah and
then once a month and his sandy high
nights he doesn't meditation to send its
energy to them to charge these bonds
what are the bands gonna do for you oh
they're gonna employee in Mick magic I
know I didn't and yeah so that was okay
go ahead I'm sorry I'm trying to get the
full picture here okay so you're selling
met in magical infinity bands that he's
gonna charge once a month via Web okay
I think he don't have one month and that
was it there was no word since not only
that then Eric you gotta charge the
Infinity bands come on buddy
go drain infinity bands what are you
doing it was a USB connection Oh
different but it used to be discard at
the time an armed escort you could see
everybody's messages and there was so
much negativity and I used to think why
is people being so negative what's going
on I didn't really want to believe it
and so I just sort of forgot about it
but he's so clamor with his CC cross and
this pit crew it's closed so you have to
be approached or um post has to be
approved though it just means if anybody
has any completes me anybody who wants
to speak domains there's no way of
getting that through his Facebook page
because everything needs to be approved
as
nada hides you wouldn't have a Facebook
page that he had approved everybody's
posts and stuff like that and so that
was either make something sucked on the
challenge there his seven-day
manifestation challenge Dan got sucked
into doing the there was another girl
doing launching business in five days
and I ball in South program first an
Anna come about things and my life I
love challenges and I was in a really
bad place and I was doing another
challenge today challenge and I of
course come across the wife yogi program
or how it was gonna change your life and
you've had when you're there all this
stuff and I was like oh my god I what
was this man he's me and I need to sign
up for this but because I already bought
the other program Isaac how can I leave
my son for time on high can i and okay
I'm a mortgage I'm gonna pay mortgage on
the Stevens for every last penny I had
into these programs and I mean
everything right down until the day
before the day I was gone
I actually tax lien and said I don't
think I can go I don't think I'd be able
to afford this and he said all we have
to go we have to go could you get paid
when you're here you get paid when
you're here and I put all my trust in
him and I had to take my be dog even and
she's 15 years old and she's got cancer
because nobody would look after and
antique or with me and they for sitting
in a B&B or air B&B
every day by ourselves why we were there
for 600 pause I'm pregnant I'm gonna
separate little camera just okay nice to
see ya but stopped into all the
challenges and pollens and programs when
Lincoln was all hyped up can't believe
I'm here can't believe we're working
with master
I am so sparsely connected and I am so
embarrassed to be even turn this call at
this present minute and hi I didn't see
the signs before but I know Nye that I
had to go I had to learn and I have to
stand up night and had prevent so many
other people from making the same
mistake I did and hopefully more and
more people will come forward but when
we got there and basically will not go
into too much but will give his basics
just showy or chai is hurt once the
first day we got there we were talking
to his office mid science stuff nobody
didn't even know we didn't even know
what to have a recital and because we
were all hyped up by all this stuff he
was tallness and Tobiah come in and they
basically stated long shortness I
thought I was gone
I told them I just wrote a book I wanted
to publish in the book and I want to
work on me charity work
oh yes master be able to happy roll out
he'll be able to give me the best
publishers and all you can make and
2,000 per giant and all this [ __ ] they
were telling us then and they took us
into room and said right and we have big
plans for the whole I am creator and
we're going to go global we're gonna be
training people up in public speaking
we're going to be training people up in
marketing would you basically would you
like to be part of the I am creator team
and come work for the I am creator
patreon duct and all these avenues
whatever you want to be trained up in
and then work worldwide who says go to
America India and be part of the team
everybody was like oh my god this is so
amazing I can't believe we get to be
part of the whole I am creator master
sri kazna
right every single person saying yes
everybody forgot about their own work we
put all our trust that this was going to
be completely life-changing
and then they give us M statistics on
how much money that will connect by each
phone call and it's program that we sell
and we're like whoa that you can make up
to a thousand dollars a call that is
high like they were selling oh sure yes
sure
so we all have to be product then we
will intense training and today except
Shauna's marketing some people have no
computer skills and I have no idea but
capful knows no idea by facebook guards
the training was that intense we were
like in there for 1415 hours a day it
was complete overload and we couldn't
even take it all in so then when we
finished our five dance I was training
on how to build exceptional then we were
sent into groups to start making kept
photos to produce for his or his GRC
programs his wife yogi programs and then
that's when the energy and the case that
we have to pay for the Facebook ads out
of our own pocket yeah but we can't
hundred pounds deposit into their
Facebook account to pay to the Facebook
ads to produce adverse to produce leads
to produce leads for a Salesforce print
in either San Diego Bangalore or London
to produce the leads to produce the
contacts to produce the telephone
numbers which we then have to follow up
in our own time is very money in order
to get a result which was not allocated
to a person at any one time and that
lead could be stolen or completed by one
of the office staff
further down the line having made the in
Rome to it and that's the chaos that
were involved in but when you're into
the spirituality world as opposed to the
hard fast
sales world which eyes more it became
dog-eat-dog and you've seen all these
lovely little fairy fairy spiritual
types turning against each other as they
bet each other's ankle to try and get a
phone call through to earn their 10%
commission there
very social experiment I found it quite
amusing but in a very tragic way right
yeah so we made our tech photos to God
entertains and then when we got into
teams everybody was just basically kill
each other so some people doing the work
and other people just doing nothing and
anybody then when we had our trip
follows me and he informed us as Paul
said you had to have five if you want
during the two-month program which cost
five thousand and he and your own
general one month you had to pay an
extra five on the time of your own money
to run a spec ads some of us was moved
over into his bedroom I was one of the
ones that was moved over into his burden
call this one little ones instead in
Halliburton once I moved over and solid
business in the first week and that's
when I started seeing what really was
going on I didn't want to believe it
but because I'm so trained in I was
picking up on all this stuff and I was
like oh my god what have I done
and and then I just goes I just can't
get caught up on this so there when
whoever didn't have the files on the
pile to run the Facebook ads it was like
I don't even want to know you there are
some was laughs it in the other bin at
this point have you already paid your
3000 or whatever yeah yeah hey your
3,000 hold on yeah you pay your 3,000
you're thinking you're gonna get rich
from this program that's the whole
reason you get in you go
basically he says okay what we're gonna
do is put you in our team right and then
you have to start by putting in five
hundred dollars into his facebook ad
account exactly in order to run ads and
generate leads for friends for him and
they're not like the stuff you paid for
is not necessarily tied back to you yeah
and you're supposed to call for him yeah
in order to get 10% of any profit
margins yeah that's the worst deal I've
ever heard of I know but
praise he has this little phrase which I
think comes I mean once I realized what
it meant because it reverse engineering
so you look at the end result and you
work work it back he's used it on a lot
of his franchise models but he's
basically cut everything to the absolute
bone to make the operators take all the
responsibilities or creating and
generating the leads activating the
leads closing the leads producing the
business to get the most absolute
minimal percentage of the end result and
then feel that they're happy with the
deal when then again there is no on sale
that leaders that not allocated to you
for a lifetime or for whatever that
client may go through the system that
you will be rewarded for how that
individual was to grow and if that group
individual was to end up as a team
leader in the space of three or four
years I have no idea who so what to
anybody and I've never seen such chaotic
rubbish in my life the the other side of
this too is that you're you're selling
to people who are then gonna become
salesman themselves in his and yeah
they'd and they don't know that it's
it's a very strange business model to be
in and I'm really happy you guys this is
why I'm happy L or speaking out is with
so many people not knowing what's
actually going on what is well Theo you
how does it even work I'm really happy
to have people who because this is the
kind of stuff I can ever get to
personally this is why I have
testimonials is because you guys have
been through it you've been through the
ropes so for anyone out there watching
wondering hey should I join you know the
wealthy okie these are two experiences
that are not you don't have master sri
looking over their shoulder right now
making sure y'all are gonna give the the
positive testimonial he wants so I'm
yeah I'm definitely absolutely
tragically because we're genuinely kind
you know down-to-earth people
we were dragged in to give great
testimonials about how much we've
learned and how much we've earned and we
haven't you guys were told by master sri
to give a testimonial Oh every day it
gets you have to start when you go there
and you know but then there's no
testimonials at the end testimonials at
the end would have been a different
story good photo collage but he gets yet
to start when you're all hyped up thing
for me is that people recognize me I was
on CC plus I was generalized videos they
were trusted me put their trust in me I
know since I've even spoke out you're
like but you were the one said it was
Korean I goes I am so sorry
and from the bottom of my heart even to
the papers I am ashamed myself when we
were told to do the calls and got the
listing I was like I had to make I had
no money I had to make my money back and
I need the cause and I got people signed
up in the program and I just goes I just
I cannot be no part of this this is not
who I am
this is not what I'm about because I am
spiritually connected and pack up in
energies it was absolutely the most
horrific experience I'm home at nights
to my Airbnb and was crying myself to
sleep
bullying email mu I mean that is
atrocious I have not seen it tell me
about it tell me about it I read it
yeah and I started putting stuff up my
facebook I'm making people aware and I
got an email today basically threatening
me
and but I won't be trans I know notice
whether these people whatsoever because
I need to prevent I basically give up a
knife on your behalf Arlene because yes
looking again to that that the world
with Bill with love Island
who was it's fair to say that joke
Arlene has had mental health issues
understandably what she's been through
and to send when we actually have to
open up all our vulnerabilities to these
I am creative people I know your
vulnerable points they know where to hit
to send this atrocity and threatened
legal action I think it's outrageous in
every wonder here this is they decide to
stand up against master it because
obviously he must have authorized this
it reads an email from creator circle om
trader calm good afternoon
Eileen it was observed by our management
team that you have published negative
videos which negatively showed and
discussed the internal materials and
content of our company's programs these
materials were provided to you during
the program time and you signed an
indemnity form which confirming that you
do not have the right to disclose any of
these provided materials although you
breached the confidentiality agreement
we would like to resolve this issue
between us you will be given a grace
period to delete all the disclosed
materials please remove these in the
next 24 hours otherwise management team
will take the appropriate legal action
against you
unbelievable unbelievable it's
completely disgusting they're
threatening you for speaking out just
get out about their program which they
signed you into the trace for Talon
they're trying to shut me up for Talon
Detroit I couldn't because I was over in
the business all the other ones that
basically left us you will not believe
the extent some of these people went
gasp monster no master tree bags full
master just to get his leg people I am
creator we often don't even get paid out
I mean there's just no it was sighing
very politely at the bottom of this
this outfit have the the audacity to say
stay blessed from the customer Oh No
hey we're about to sue you stay blessed
da just at least leave me and paws off
not [ __ ] sorry I still can't get past
the fact that he's threatening a single
mother who's lost $10,000 nice memory
lost ten thousand dollars to his course
and then he's saying stay blessed I
can't get what does that do to you
as someone who's just trying to recover
I mean you talked about the emotional
toll this is done to you can you speak a
little bit to that so after you after
everything kind of happened after you
realized you said you'd kind of caught
on what happened before when I come home
from the program I was broken I was
broken I tried to get back on my feet I
got seriously is a christmas to extent i
was in cardiac arrest and i was brought
back i was it was just the impact and
stress of everything that I'd been
through all the long hours we were doing
four or five hours of yoga to turn the
morning train in England
16 17 hours a day I will look back on it
I said what the hell we even Pike would
be even thinking so i from pain ii
getting better I've come to realize
everything that he was teaching none of
it makes even sense everything that I've
been doing this last couple of years I
was going against myself I was working
from the ego enough from the soul I was
basically chasing and that was saving
but it's not me to guess that to realize
how much I've learned and I can put that
in to happen my clients night I haven't
change our lives the right way can I ask
you horrid horrid did you say you went
into cardiac arrest
and yes it brought back six hours it
took them to stabilize me I'm not be
telling our hospital even I was so so L
I'm the cause of all the trauma of what
happened
I just basically give up I didn't want
to be here anymore
and not to be
so a taste and I've started my special
traits and I'm doing things the right
way and I've changed my whole life
around within weeks I have got this
inner strength it was the other day four
people contacted me about stuff that was
going on and as advice people contact me
just wanna move on and won't forget
about this whole experience and
something just clicked and I goes does
it I've had enough I have to speak out
and coz holdin all that stress and stuff
in was I can't move forward until I tell
the truth and learn art and I think I by
doing this I can move forward with my
life if I'm not taking the court in
church and we were basically used talk
on the phone or pay your own money to
appease the gods
use your own phones sell his horse Sally
his course and then at the end of it
have a nice life see you later good luck
nice to meet you left hung and right
this is heart I mean honestly this is
heartbreaking III heard I've heard
recently I don't know if you guys have
followed this there's another guru
Samuel Leeds who he had he had a student
killed himself after after his program
now now I'm not gonna say they were
related I'm only gonna say I took the
program he was an ex that and basically
he was in a lot of debt
he was very stressed out because of the
debt and he ended up sadly very I mean
tragically committing suicide yeah I
said your mind in your mind have things
gone too far with these gurus who are
charging people up and up and up and up
and up promising up and up and up and up
and up targeting them more and more and
more and more vulnerable what's our
darts they don't realize they make like
their change in people's eyes no but
nobody's showing the other side of it
they're people that they're breaking and
that's why I wanted to speak out because
like I the part really pissed me off as
well if you don't succeed he makes like
that you don't put in the effort and you
don't change
so it's a win-win-win situation Fred yes
but for me because I am anybody it knows
me anybody that knows me on Facebook
knows how driven I'm positive and I put
my heart and soul into everything and I
never give up and I put everything into
this to be left to shaft and basically
that's what we were left shafted it was
talking about the heavy big cell on
being agents for kangen water is that
worth talking about a hundred percent
it's worth talking about I okay so I
heard I heard about this I heard like
rumors about this link for everyone who
doesn't know kangen water is an MLM
multi-level marketing right which many
people in America hold to be pyramid
schemes equivalent to pyramid schemes
but what will let that lie he was trying
to recruit you guys into that every
single person within there was not put
the project as a teen thing like master
standing up and saying I think well you
got stand up and say the kangen water is
good stuff but every one of his office
staff will sneak round one of the tables
from time to time I don't know why but
no one approached me I don't know why
that was but everybody else they came up
and said we're agents for kangen water
this negatively ions come alkali water
which is all the rage and all the health
health thing yes save your life Sega
answer Savior whatever yeah well even to
the extent that the water within what we
drank within the office had to be canned
in water we weren't allowed to drink tap
water and the kettle had to be boiled
with kangen water and because of the
negative energies obviously we weren't
allowed in microwave because you can
understand a microwave and all that sort
of energy just would've affected us in
all our sales approaches oh my god I
can't imagine yeah so we just had a
little hot stove you know that when we
weren't farming or doing it out with
rubbing boy sticks links boyscouts links
together to make open fires to manifest
around each other
we have to you did a lot of things
around fires didn't you you did the chai
Indian New Year round a big open fire
didn't you yeah are you away they done a
fire on Sunday night now but it was the
way they've done it they took me up into
the office they're like oh can I talk to
you in there like oh we would like you
to be part of our meds and tank water
group because your hair so amazing and
you would be in the front of our adverts
and we think you'd be so me isn't and
Isaac right okay and I need to stage
what was grown as a guarantor so I am
back over to the other bed that I said
so a couple of ones I was only up to try
to get me to sign up for this kind of
water [ __ ] I'm the brought me aside and
they're like oh my god same thing to me
and I was like what the hell I cannot
stand sneaking around and [ __ ] if
they had to talk the whole daughter was
in and said we work with cannon water
would you like to be part of it and be
part of the great for whatever instead
of sneaking everybody around making me
sleep squash I'll get you signed up get
you signed up and away you go I've got
to ask because I heard this from
somebody I heard that Eric was allegedly
threatening people with dark energies
who weren't paying up is that true he's
my camphor tree and an Indian mine and
contacted me the other day he was doing
the FLC program and because it was so
bad he stopped it putting in a monthly
payment scheme and he stopped him from
taking the payments out on a certain
member again rang him and said the dark
energies would come back on you and
you've been affected by the law of
attraction because you're not making
these payments and I was sick too so
much I'm not sure they believed in the
law of attraction no I don't I don't
think and the personally I mean we
cannot know we cannot know but I don't
think they do because they
they wouldn't be doing much idea because
does not law of attraction they wouldn't
be contradicting themselves by taking
papers money often and real stuff but
then just shasta and basically it's all
everything is just basically money doc
doesn't forget and I was on you've got
to manifest your Lambo somehow I mean
you got a manifest available you know to
be fair
did he not put out all the fires in
Australia with his meditation
oh yeah that's racist what man that's
gay
I don't know what to say I owe shames no
no she I'm whatsoever what did you guys
do in the aftermath of this programming
I mean obviously I think a lot of people
probably left like you guys kind of
bewildered by what happens what dr.
Wilden and I children after experience
okay I didn't do anything that wasn't by
my own free will
I had greater expectations between no
way were fulfilled and I don't believe
with a bunch of crooks like that that
it's it's wasted energy trying to book
bits of paper to refund as far as what
we were sold and what we got out of it
it was rubbish
it was pathetic I there's people that
sold their houses there's people that
don't all this don't know yeah I they're
doing what they have to generate to
leverage back what they have to guess
but where I think I just can't
understand knowing what we went through
how can you sell something to somebody
else knowing exactly what what you're
selling ripping people off to go through
what we went through
that's what really pisses me off really
annoys me so much Paul you seem to be
very this less affected by all of this
then Eileen is it fair to say you're
kind of here for moral support or you
you feel bad about
what happened to her or are you here for
your own reasons feeling that you know
you you also feel obligated to tell
people about what happened I'm not here
because Eileen's billing I believe it
everything that she said and I've been
half of that it has other things that we
have token about because I'm trying to
keep a little bit of the reins on Eileen
not to get into the areas not provable
let's just talk about what actually
happened because that's important it
cannot be denied I do very much stand my
ground then I was a bit of a devil's
advocate up there I was not on it
Eileen got a listed selected initially
until she found out what was going on my
feelings have been made known very very
early that that this was towards a lot
of gullible people that the course of
not fit for purpose we had other things
in there which are quite horrific which
are the fact that the man management of
the whole course of people with
accommodation and another shark that
sucked a few of the girls in with
accommodation and disposed car rental
that didn't happen which I helped bail
them out on that and financially got
embarrassed in that instance as well but
this is where the whole structure of the
course is organized like a couple of a
couple of teenagers trying to organize a
scout camp in the forest and it's
completely completely wrong it has those
script rapture it has no function and it
has no any product when that email came
through today that really enticed me I
was going to come on and talk to you but
you seem like a good bloke you seem you
got your head screwed on and without
people like you that are prepared to
that have got the the outlets to to
highlight these things that going on if
you can save a few people from wasting
15,000 pounds and getting close I mean I
didn't know till after the effect
although I was in contact with Arlene
she's her own person it only came to
light way after Christmas because where
everyone was doing their own thing
that she got to sort like a near-death
experience there's no
course or business opportunity in this
world that is worthy of putting yourself
through that girl you know it was you
know it's not acceptable and with all
the things that are currently in the
press it's an absolute atrocity that
that email that came through this
afternoon threatening with you legal
action well they've got my goat and now
it will I will go all the way with this
this can go out to all the people that
we know because you know you're just
they're just a few little school
children playing with business up there
they haven't met the real world and the
real world is just about to come up and
[ __ ] hittin our o [ __ ] with things you
don't understand so this is just the
beginning because when you put this out
and it goes live it's going to bring
other people out of the woodwork I don't
know what it will produce but what we've
said is honest and truthful to how we
went through it no more no less
thank you thank you Paul Thank You
Eileen thank you so much for being able
to give us this opportunity just I've
seen so many other people your voices
deserve to be heard I strongly believe
that I think that customer testimonials
the idea that only positive customer
testimonials should exist is insane and
I think it's damaging to people's lives
so I mean you guys are the ones who are
you know risking so much to come out and
speak again thank you guys
with that said everybody that's all for
now we will talk later thank you
[Music]
[Music]